I think maybe one difference for us is
that we think of this not as hey here's
something that you know forces you or
tries to engage you more and suck you
more in trap locations but again your
hires to get a job done the job is not
to spend more time in the application
the job is to be more productive the job
is to get this document done the job is
to finish this proposal and therefore
our goal is not with all of these
different parts of our experiences to
have more minutes in our application
because that's not what you pay us for
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes Inga dr.
Johannes gurkha is a Microsoft technical
fellow and head of architecture and
machine learning for the intelligent
communications and conversations cloud
in Microsoft's experiences and devices
division the lest you think his lofty
position makes him in any way superior
to you let me tell you he knows who
works for whom and he'll be the first to
tell you that you are his boss on
today's podcast dr. Guerra frames the
new cloud powered work world as a fast
paced widely distributed workplace that
demands real-time decision-making in
collaboration and explains how products
like Microsoft teams are meeting those
demands and tells us both directly and
indirectly about the future of work
which for Microsoft involves a pivot
from an app centric approach to a people
centric approach where by using an AI
infused productivity suite coupled with
the power of the cloud we can
essentially hire Microsoft to help us
get our work done that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
yo.hannes Gurkha welcome to the podcast
it's great to be here I like to begin
each podcast by introducing and
situating my guests to use a research
term so here we go for you and it's long
it's a mouthful what you do you're a
Microsoft technical fellow and you're
the chief architect and head of AI and
machine learning for the intelligent
communications and conversations cloud
in Microsoft's experiences and devices
group there's a lot to unpack there so
we will in a second but first since
you're currently working under the
product mantle but you have a PhD in
deep roots in research tell us how that
all comes together for you what do you
do for a living why do you do it what
gets you up in the morning well in the
morning usually it's just a good cup of
coffee but so what I'm doing my job I'm
responsible busy for two things one of
them is architecture so for example in
the intelligent indication conversations
cloud one of the things we're doing is
were powering Microsoft teams which is
sort of a chat based experience
where you know you'll be sent messages
back and forth and we have an existing
chat service that has reached its age
and we're now we're now designing a new
chat service I've been very deeply
involved in helping with that design I'm
also responsible for artificial
intelligence or machine learning and
tell me much more about this but
basically what we're doing is there
we're taking a bunch of existing code
and replacing it with models and we're
both creating therefore more robust
experiences as well as new innovative
experiences for our customers then I'm
also responsible for innovation it's not
only me it's the whole team but I'm
especially interested in this given my
research background and this is
especially exciting in the context of
Microsoft Research because I get the
opportunity to work closely with
Microsoft Research and Redmond I work
with Microsoft Research in India and
also MSR a so for example this summer I
am Co supervising a few interns here at
Microsoft Research actually instead of
the data base area but just to keep my
research muscle going and as part of
that I'm also therefore responsible for
mentoring some of the principal
engineers so I'm actually working with
several engineers across the team to see
you know who is the next generation of
architect
for our team so let's unpack a couple of
those meaty phrases experiences and
devices is this a fairly new umbrella if
you will it's broad enough to include
just about anything that has to do with
computing can you sharpen the focus a
bit in short experiences and devices
pedra combines windows office devices
and browsers so those four things okay
but really what this means is that the
core there's this group of products that
we call Microsoft 365 which is basically
our productivity cloud that spans both
work and life mm-hmm and it's this
communication collaboration platform for
all of our customers and it integrates
business processes directly in our
experiences and it Income Security for
devices and applications so it's really
a big comprehensive productivity
solution for all of our customers and
what has changed there and that's maybe
where the sort of the E&D focus comes in
that it used to be very AB centric so we
used to have Outlook which was like
messaging and calendaring right then we
a chair point which was about documents
and workflows and content management and
so on
and there we have Skype and Skype for
business for real-time communication and
we basically in the consumer world we
had a sort of similar app centric world
view that's basically one dry they were
Skype and there was hotmail right and
what we've recently done is we've
changed this and pivoted this to put the
customer at the center so people are
really at the center of the suite and so
we have now workflows that go across all
of the different devices and apps
basically get the job done mm-hmm so the
way I like to think about actually
everything that we're building is that
you basically hire Microsoft products to
get a job done hmm so when you need to
have the job done you'd have to have all
of these digital assets at your
fingertips right all right so drilling
in there just a little bit if I'm the
customer and I'm used to an app centric
world in fact I even conceptualize
things as I'm gonna get an app for that
there's got to be an app for that
right how does it change my experience
if you make a a Microsoft say you're the
center now yeah it's pretty transparent
for you and it basically means that we
bring sort of the power of the whole
suite this integrated across all of the
different apps
make workflows across some pretty
seamless okay for example assume you're
an Outlook now you would like to attach
a document to your meeting request or
even to your email mm-hmm well now you
click on attach file and a very simple
experiences now that we actually show
you the mru which was the most recently
used files that you had because that's
very often the file that you want to
attach there next we have a lot of lemon
tree that shows us what I've actually
the recent files you can think of this
like a brain that example because why
didn't we do this before but this is an
example of when I'm an Outlook I think
about well I want to open up a file box
and then you know let you pick the right
file
whichever think across the suite will
think oh actually I've worked on a file
before in SharePoint that if edited that
and I want to share with you right and
the average should directly be there at
your fingertips well I love that you
called it an mru and then immediately
told me what that meant because I was
gonna ask em are you everything's at TLA
a three-letter acronym right but the
automatically knowing what I just did is
this involve a lot of machine learning
algorithms that are looking at what I'm
doing and sort of processing how does
that right so that that actually a thing
is now we're a little bit the power of
the cloud comes in so if you look at
previous generations of software never
busy you're running on premise you
basically had all the data there as well
but it wasn't really utilized whereas
now we have the power of the cloud were
basically every interaction with the
system for Microsoft gets recorded and
it's not that now we software engineers
can play around with it because mics
would actually has very strict controls
of what it can look at and what not but
week actually now make this data
available for all of our customers to
build interesting applications on focus
on what we can now do is we can compute
the list of the people that you're
working with and this is not only the
people that you're emailing with a lot
this is not the people that you're
sharing documents often with a lot these
are not the people that you're chatting
with a lot on teams but the combination
of all of them so basically what we can
do is we can take all of these signals
and rank them and then see oh we're the
people that you actually working with
you and there are many other
applications or it's noise like this
across the suite interesting because I'm
looking at it from you know a broader
perspective of how software works on
social media for example snapchat would
have the person that you snap the most
right and it knows automatically because
it's collecting
data and and then hopefully serving is
you don't to scroll down your list if
they're in the lower in the alphabet
yeah I think that's very similar to that
I think maybe one difference for us is
that we think of this not as hey here's
something that you know forces you or
tries to engage you more and suck you
more into applications but again your
hires to get a job done the job is not
to spend more time in the application
the job is to be more productive the job
is to get this document done the job is
to finish this proposal and therefore
our goal is not with all of these
different parts of our experiences to
have more minutes in our application
because that's not what you pay us for
and so therefore in some of the metrics
that we're optimizing for are very
different than you know various consumer
companies you know I'm grinning so big
right now because the way you frame this
is you're working for me and I'm
thinking yeah that's right for me don't
make me do what you want me to do do you
do what I want to do well how about this
phrase the intelligent communications
and conversations cloud when I first
read it I wanted to put an ins ax like
intelligent communications conversations
in the cloud right but that's not it it
is the cloud right it's actually the
thing the thing right so give us a
picture of what this is because I do
want to talk about your role in the
division but tell us more a little bit
about the intelligent communications and
conversations cloud I think it came from
the observation that as businesses are
transforming and getting more
distributed and decision-making is
getting faster and faster Communications
and especially real-time communications
is becoming much more important and
real-time collaboration as well and
really that's what Microsoft teams is
all about and in a way is that it's sort
of a new application that brings chat at
the center but really collaboration is
at the center of the education teams has
these four different capabilities built
into it that are sort of living of this
communication conversations cloud so the
first one is basically it has video
conferencing in meetings so if you are
now sitting not in the same studio here
but then they could be using teams to
just collaborate together directly and
see each other
it is collaboration built-in and that we
can quite a documents together and
basically in a way the sort of office
build in
- the single shell and anything that we
can do in office we can do directly
within teams and then it also integrates
through these other business workflows
that if you're working on third-party
tools then we can actually integrate
that all together into teams as well
really so example third-party tool so
for example I mean you know I said
offices sort of built in but there's
also planner building and there's github
and there's sort of a long tail of other
applications that you can directly just
hook up to teams and then you have sort
of your workflow directly at your
fingertips so how new is all of this so
I think the general model was pioneered
by slack which was a competitor and they
sort of had this observation that many
third-party applications can actually
have a messaging interface and so you
sort of when you check something in you
get a return message and so we're using
the same model as well and then we have
a lot of other innovative ideas around
how we expose this directly in the UX to
our customers as well well switching
streams here a little because we're
gonna come back to teams and some other
things that you're working on but one of
your big research interests is database
systems in fact you're a bit of an
expert in that area you co-authored a
book called database management systems
way back when it's a leading text for
database education courses and the field
has changed a lot since the most recent
edition of the book in 2002 I think that
was the third edition so tell us what
the database systems landscape looked
like when this book came out in 2002 the
third edition because you alluded to the
fact that it didn't change a lot in the
first three editions but things have
gotten way different now what changes
have you seen to warrant the additions
and what might future editions look like
so this is actually an interesting story
so this book was written by my adviser
the first edition Raghu Rama Krishna and
when it joined as a PhD student I was
actually really interested in writing
and we talked a lot about the book and
at some point in time he said well I'm
writing a second edition would you like
to join me and so I joined the second
edition and then we wrote the third
edition and basically the book gives you
a really deep introduction of what it
takes to build a relational database
system sort of you know sequel server
Oracle's really the hallmarks of
traditional data management system and I
think now databases have changed
significantly so I
especially the move to the cloud has
changed many things usually the first
attempt of bringing any system into the
cloud sort of this lift and shift you
take the on-premise system and you just
run it in the cloud but that only brings
you so far and I think one of the main
misunderstandings of the cloud is that
it's just about cost savings and
multi-tenancy in elasticity but it's
really about standing of the shoulders
of giants
yeah see basically somebody builds
something really awesome and then
everybody can use it
and that's not what's happening in the
database community so people have
started to busy go ahead and build these
cloud native database systems that are
supposed to be designed for the cloud
that build another cloud infrastructure
pieces and that looks very different
than the traditional relational database
systems what is all the changes that
they're for a bunch of other aspects
have become much more important for
example distribution and wide area
availability has become super important
distributed database systems used to be
a niche area but now with the cloud and
sort of 24/7 availability across
different zones I just remember when the
terabyte was called the terabyte
terabyte and now we have you know
exabytes of data so it is an even set of
bytes and even zettabytes it's really
grown so much over the last decade
really and nor the last two decades that
the book has really become somewhat
outdated no so the last edition was 2002
it's now 2019
is there another edition coming out yes
sir Raghu and I have been talking and
every year we sort of sit and ruminate
and say yes we should do it at least
right now we're talking and you know
we're thinking about bringing out
another edition I think what has changed
us a little bit is that you know when
you would have asked me 15 years back or
so what is a database system I think it
was clear to everybody what a database
system is and I think over the last
decade this has also changed quite a lot
so I think we're now early even in
understanding what are sort of the
lasting principles again for this next
class of database systems I think early
on was clear you know on the theory side
maybe you need to know the relational
algebra there's an indexer to the beach
we there is a very well understood
notion of what concurrency control and
recovery means there's a very well
understood notion of what serialize
ability
and now in the cloud everything has
changed so it's not anymore
clear what it actually means to be sort
of a first-class native assistant right
now and what the foundations are I hope
you have a big team there's a lot of
thinking I mean it isn't just the work
to do there's the the conceptual work
upfront well I want to talk about some
interesting work you're involved in and
I'm going to suggest that we go sort of
free-range here because there's a lot of
moving parts and pieces as we've just
discussed all of it has to do with as
you've alluded to earlier technologies
that help us work better and smarter in
different ways right so talk about the
spectrum of projects you've got going
and how they're manifesting either as
products or in products because that's
the other thing you're no longer just
doing boxes of software and saying here
buy this it just appears right in my
workflow so talk about that yeah so when
I first came to Microsoft I came with
the idea to build something that we
called at that point in time delve and
the office graph so I used to work in
enterprise search on a startup that
actually Marcus not required in 2008 but
an enterprise search we always had this
kind of frustrating experience that we
would basically sell our software and we
had customers like Best Buy Financial
Times and so on and they would buy our
enterprise search software and then we'd
have on consultants go in and customize
it then afterwards it looked like a
black box then when we came to Microsoft
now we're running suddenly in the cloud
what this actually means is that we now
see all of these signals so when you go
ahead and share a file with me that's
actually a signal that we're
collaborating right so if you think
about now search in the enterprise as
compared to search on the Internet
certain Enterprise has never been as
great as in the Internet now in the
enterprise you have you know small and
large enterprises but you have a reduced
audience and they're not searching all
the time see if much less engagement you
have many fewer links and the content is
spread across all these different one
drives and SharePoint sites and you
don't really know which of them
is much more important than the other so
enterprise search by itself is much
harder problem so what it didn't Elvis
we said well let's build an underlying
data asset and we called it at that
point in time the office graph and then
it became the Microsoft graph and in the
office graph you would capture all of
these signals that came from people just
working in the cloud and these signals
now help us to do ranking much much
better in the enterprise and because it
sounds kind of abstract and the office
graph sort of as a data asset is kind of
abstract we built in delft as an
experience on top of it where Delft is
basically people centric search so I
could go to your Delft and I would see
all the documents that you're working on
and sort of your organization is working
around you and you do the species
irrelevance feat that comes from
everything around you so that was Delft
and that was really exciting because in
a weight shift it also I think offers a
little bit from this app centric view to
more of a data centric view yeah and
also to this people centric view and
then more recently over the last couple
of years I've been working on teams and
teams I started mainly with architecture
because they were basically a bunch of
things that I think were older systems
that we needed to bring into the modern
cloud-based area but in addition then
recently I started to also look at AI
and machine learning and they're
especially what I've been looking at is
what's called software to that oh it's
basically you know your place code with
coding data and you've manifested alien
models right especially deep neural
networks and so we're basically on a
journey where we take pieces of team
software and replace them with deep
neural networks and we have lots of
individual components and these
components were built at different times
and what we're doing now is replacing
this whole pipeline basically with deep
neural networks what's your timeline on
this so that we can ship something later
this year and then all throughout next
year I'm going off script here but how
cognizant our customers now that this is
happening and is this going to be
surprising to put it nicely or
disturbing that it knows you know that's
the phrase I use now it knows how are
you assimilating these products into
people's lives right yeah I think it's a
bit of a journey
seven when we first brought out Delft
again Delft works on all of the existing
customer signals these are actually
signals that the customer has access to
already right so who has updated a
document you can look at the document
version history you can look at your
email to see what you're communicating
on the other hand we had some customers
who said well you should turn valve off
mm-hmm because they said well this is
something that is maybe to privacy
invasive right so I think this is also
an important lesson that we learned that
even though the data may be out there
the information that you in substance
cook out of it may still be more
disturbing than the individual pieces of
data that just lying dispersed out there
and we'll come back to the what keeps
you up in that question in a second or
what keeps me up at night and I hope
you're working on is probably better
because I think what we're seeing now is
a shift in the idea of privacy you know
what trade-off am I willing to make for
this super productivity promises that I
get from what you're saying hey we just
want to help you get the job done we're
working for you it's like well what do I
have to let you know so that you can
help me work yeah that's a really good
question I think there probably two
different scenarios out there there's a
scenario where you're in the control of
your data and then there's the other
scenario which is usually the work
scenario where actually your employer
owns all the data at least in the United
States exactly right yeah and so I think
there you know I can at least say so
when I first came to Microsoft the one
thing I was most impressed by it was how
strong the controls are that we have
against our own engineers to get at any
kind of customer data absolutely I have
never seen in my whole time yet
Microsoft a single piece of customer
data I wouldn't be able to log into the
machines there's like triple escalation
barriers in between we have customer key
in customer lockbox so so we have
actually extremely strong controls in
there to protect the privacy of our
customers visual I think the red light
going off and exactly well it's
interesting I just had Guinness and
Anthony Ryan and who's doing computer
vision and as a researcher he wants
access to camera feeds and he says it's
both frustrating and reassuring that I
can't write even as a research
see I can make products better if I had
that data in Microsoft says nope
yeah exactly that's sort of this
interesting tension so for example what
we're there for trying to use a lot our
mechanisms like reinforcement learning
yeah we're basically in some sense the
model adjusts itself and we have sort of
controls over the model that it
hopefully doesn't go off the rails but
basically training models where we never
see the model we only see the customer
signals but you only don't see them in
plain text either right we only see
something about the performance of the
model yes everything is basically done
indirectly even for Dell of the people
ranking that we have again we can
compute a people ranking for you which
are the your colleagues and then we see
your engagement on it yeah and if you
always click on person number 15 but not
of the first 14 that gives us a somewhat
of a signal that the ranking is maybe
not the right ranking well while we're
on the topic of technology that helps us
get work done I'd like to touch on a
subject that everyone is talking about
and one that's actually a theme of
Microsoft Research is faculty summit
this year and it's this small topic of
the future of work so since you're
giving a keynote on that subject this
year what do we need to know or at least
what thoughts could you share about this
subject of the future of work first of
all I think the future of work is going
to be powered by data and the idea is
that we can make you more productive
with all the data that both you and all
of your colleagues and all the people
around you leave in the cloud
our goal at Microsoft at least is always
to put the user at the center and the
user in control so I think delve is one
such example where we really put people
at the center and then make search
personalized the person relevance feed
another example is what we're doing
right now with teams again we're trying
to use AI to make you more productive
and not to suck you into our
applications I think what's also
important is that we use the data to
make you more productive rather than to
tell your manager you know oh you
clocked in at nine o'clock and you left
right at four o'clock today because we
leave that you know goals are aligned
if you become more productive that helps
the enterprise as well our goal is to
make you as a person overall more
productive or make a team more
productive so that's one thing about the
future of work one other kinds of things
computer science wise could we think
about
so I think what also changes is how we
as software developers work I mean this
comes back into this software to that
old theme that previously you hired
experts in an area and these experts
they sort of transferred in some sense
their expert knowledge from their head
into code and now what we have to do is
we have to collect data and then we take
basis of this data and now we have
machine learning experts and what these
machine learning experts do is they take
the data and then transform into a model
okay and then we transform this model
into code and what this means is that
actually everything that we know about
software infrastructure is not changing
quite a bit as well for example for you
know if you think about software 100 we
have lots of really great tooling we
have tooling around repeatability around
testing we have ways of decomposing
software into modules we have great ways
of the bogging software you know good
luck will be parking a deep net and we
have we have really good ways of
abstractions we have high level
languages you know optimizing compilers
we have performance tuners and we have
cervical dev ops culture it is basically
taking software from the computer
science discipline really into an
engineering design now in the software
to that o world we don't have really
that well developed tools or
infrastructure for all of these aspects
for some of our repeatability well maybe
we have model pipelines and environments
for freezing cold for testing we have
maybe test generation with ganz we have
simulated environments we have
adversarial training and testing for
debugging I think it's a very nascent
field for deep nets in terms of
abstractions you know for software
though we don't have really great
abstractions I mean here if you think
you interviewed Patrice MRI machine yeah
I think could be an interesting
abstraction right odd ml give this North
media variable hello Susie that and back
to what you're talking before about Tom
Zimmerman was recently on about
data-driven decision-making for software
productivity for software engineers all
these pieces are mind-boggling and so
exciting right so there's a whole
development from basically traditional
DevOps and to data-driven DevOps right
then to data-driven Devils with models
actually in it
and then all the way sort of in the end
this may be software to that oh I always
think that you know there's a spectrum
from 100 to 200 and we're clearly not
there to that o yet but we're somewhere
in the middle maybe at 1.5 or 1.6 or so
so johannes I've asked several guests on
the show to give us their take on the
value of research or maybe more
specifically the value of research
models since we're talking about models
where do you fall on this spectrum of
publish or perish versus ship or perish
should we let a thousand flowers bloom
or should we try to do fewer things and
do them better or both or what I think
clearly both but I think also this sort
of publisher perish or ship or perish
models maybe yeah I never thought about
this way when it was an assistant
professor at Cornell one of the things
is clearly on top of your mind is how do
you get tenure and actually the answer
which I found very satisfying was that
you just have to do great research and
changes the world now you can see this
in two ways right you can either say wow
this sounds really scary because there
no metrics so I'm doomed anyway or you
can say well this sounds really great
because I'll just do whatever I'm best
at and what I have fun and hopefully
that'll work out so I think in research
what you basically therefore have to do
is you have to find an a research area
where you think you can make a big
difference and during that time you sort
of really scramble you'll be very fast
you try lots of little experiments and
once you've found an area then you can
go deep with research at that one time
you then take your time so you sort of
have this fast part or this exploratory
part and then actually some sort of a
deeper part because you make some
certain bets and it's sort of a
combination of let a thousand flowers
bloom but then also some of them you
actually now you know want to really
build a greenhouse and or maybe want to
go sort of really big production right
and actually the product wall is very
similar basically you want to try as
quickly as possible what you want to
build and there may be lots of different
risks you know there could be technology
or it could be people risk or product
market fit risks but once you have found
a good match for all of these three then
again you want to take your time because
now you want to create a product that
customers love and so you in both sides
I think you have to scramble let a
thousand flowers bloom let's explore
but then you want to make a few bets and
then go deep in them all right we've
reached the point in the podcast where I
asked what could possibly go wrong I
asked everybody this mainly to just kind
of get out there the fact that people
are thinking ahead in terms of what
they're doing and not just saying well
I'm just doing what I'm doing and you
all can deal with it later when things
break or if things go wrong so is there
anything about what you're doing you've
alluded to a couple of things already
that literally or figuratively keeps you
up at night I think the main thing that
keeps me up at night now that I'm in a
product group is to make sure that our
service is running 24/7 and I've always
been impressed by how professional that
side of the whole cloud at Microsoft is
so I think what's really important is
that we have our services up and running
24/7 for our customers but at the same
time that we can allow a certain amount
of innovation and innovation means
change and we have to manage that risk
between the two of them and their we
have to have the right kind of
mechanisms in place that we can roll out
change without impacting our customers
but at the same time understanding
whether this is a stable build for
example or with a Daniel regressions or
anything like this so when you're
talking about that I mean literally
you're not up at night probably some I'm
up at night as well some time time an
incident manager I think it's important
that also people who are not that close
to any of the actual code that they
understand what it means to run at
service 24/7 if you've never experienced
that pain then you actually don't really
know what you're talking about
and so I think everybody in our
leadership team actually is an incident
manager you know and maybe every eight
or ten weeks or so and therefore when
there's an incident that I'm actually
also up in the middle of the night if
necessary but then also it shows us how
good our tools are because if there is
an incident we try to mitigate it very
quickly and often it happens very very
quickly it's right I think it just
speaks to sort of how we work as a team
and that basically everybody has to
pitch in
here I think it's important to really
understand what our customers experience
right because otherwise you don't
develop that kind of customer empathy
right and so therefore as soon as we
hear something like this we try to
respond extremely quickly and basically
mitigate the incident as quickly as
possible all right so you are actually
the first guest on the podcast that says
I'm literally up at night I want to get
just a little personal with you because
you have a funny story about having come
to Microsoft twice tell us how you got
here the first time what happened in
between and how you ended up where you
are now so I joined a start-up in 2005
because two of my colleagues at Cornell
were already with the startup the start
was called fast search and transfer it
wasn't Norwegian business intelligence
search company and it happened by the
CTO you're an all-star who is now a good
friend of mine he came to Cornell to
give a talk and then we had have our
meeting and they ended up talking for
like two or three hours at that one time
I didn't know anything about search but
I learned there are lots of interesting
database and distributed systems
problems out there too which I actually
had some interesting thoughts then I
became an adviser to the company and
then I had a sabbatical in 2007 or 2008
where then worked for fast from Germany
and then actually during 2008 fast was
acquired by Microsoft so that's when I
actually got my blue badge for the first
time but then I actually went back to
Cornell because of that one time I
couldn't think about leaving academia
then in 2012 runs I had this other idea
together with people from fast where we
were then building Delft in the office
graph so I thought well you know I
really want to build this and Microsoft
is the place to build it because it has
all the data so I negotiated the year of
leaf and so I joined Microsoft again
during that time I had a fantastic time
at Cornell but there were so many more
things to learn here at this point in
time but I thought I'll stay here and so
far it's been a fantastic right here I
mean I had a really fantastic time at
Cornell and at fast but it's also really
great here to be at Microsoft right in
your Microsoft proper not Microsoft
Research correct sign in a product group
I'm actually in this experiences and
devices the mouthful we talked about is
MacKinnon
which is interesting too because I don't
think there are all that many PhDs
flowed
around in private groups or are there
more than we know actually there are
more than you would think of so my team
is full of PhDs these are amazing
machine learning experts then even
throughout the product teams we have
many PhDs for example especially you
know audio-video stack VF PhDs
we have PhDs in our distribute systems
group that builds a chat service so you
wouldn't imagine I mean Microsoft is
actually full of smart people well we
know that and I'm learning from them
everyday assets it's just crawling with
phd's all right well my newest fun
question for my guests is tell us one
thing we might not know about you if we
did a web search you know the standard
things would show up but this might not
an interesting characteristic life event
personal quirk sidequest adeno that may
have shaped informed or influenced your
career as a researcher do you have
anything so when I first came to the US
I came in 1993 and I especially I came
to UT Austin because I wanted to work
with avi solutions who is actually my
flight visors advisor so I'm sort of
like grandfather advisor but actually
that year he left to Bela's so I was
actually there Duty Austin and there was
one database person there but I found
this other really great adviser great
Plex and he was a theoretician and he
was actually working algorithms so for
two years I actually worked with him on
algorithms and I learned so much from
him but also learned that I'm not a
really great algorithms researcher so
after two years actually then switched
to Wisconsin where I started to work
with Raghu Rama Krishnan but I think
what these two years told me is that
there's great value in writing things
down precisely there's great value in
thinking formally about problems and I
think you do awesome in general the
training there was very good at that and
I think it still influences my research
in that whenever there's a good question
I don't try to jump to the first answer
but I try to understand you know has
this question being solved before or
maybe even in the theory community and
how does it relate to sort of more
formal problems that maybe other people
have looked at I'm actually sad that our
time is coming to a close Johannes this
has been more fun than I expected
that's a terrible situation that's great
[Laughter]
at the end of every podcast I give my
guests a chance to say anything they
want to our listeners and often it's in
the form of advice or encouragement
sometimes it's you know cautionary tales
things I wish I would have known
something profound unrelated but
interesting you get the last word what
do you say so maybe two or three things
the first one is I'm a big believer in
habits like similar to what our software
does that it teaches you workflows I
think in your personal life as well I'm
a really big believer in that you should
have certain workflows or habits and
then these habits determine who you are
and what you do but also what you become
and so therefore just by setting the
right kind of expectations starting with
very small mini habits and then growing
them over time you can change who you
are significantly second of all I think
should put people to the center in your
life you know wherever you are what you
want to work with is the right people
the smartest people the best people and
it's the people that matter in the end
and it's just great to have these kind
of relationships and all the kind of
guidance and help from other people and
advice and that have been with you
throughout the whole career and the last
thing you know coming back to this sort
of career notion I think you to be
proactive about your career nobody's
going to look out for your career except
yourself
other people they will give you advice
but also only if you ask them right so
there are lots of benevolent people out
there they'll help you but without you
being proactive about learning and
contributing you're not going to grow
and you know especially then also wants
you to reach a certain level and and
maybe seniority in the community it's
also up to you to mentor and give that
the next generation yo.hannes gurkha
thank you for joining us today thank you
very much Scratchy
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. yo.hannes caucus
and how the intelligent communications
and conversations cloud is helping us
gear done visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]